on va continuer tout de suite si vous le
voulez bien ce soir avec Julie Bouchard
qui est président de la Fédération
interprète professionnelle de la santé
et Patrice Lapointe président de
l'association des entreprises privées de
personnels soignants bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir madame Bouchard d'abord le
gouvernement donc qui se donne 3 ans là
pour cesser d'avoir recours aux agences
privées comment les infirmières comment
la figue accueille le projet de loi
premièrement le projet de loi en tant
que tel est une chose puisque pour nous
il représente très peu le projet de loi
il y a pas grand chose dedans qui vient
baliser beaucoup par contre quand on a
eu la conférence de presse de Monsieur
Dubé ou là il y a eu vraiment le
verbaliser l'ensemble des mesures
c'était plus intéressant un petit peu
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir mis les
règlements futurs qu'il veut ajouter au
projet de loi directement dans le projet
de loi il aurait été beaucoup plus
mordant et le sérieux aurait été
autrement puisque c'est une volonté
politique maintenant on le sait de
pouvoir mettre fin à la main d'oeuvre
indépendante mais quoi de mieux que le
justifier réellement dans un projet donc
ça démonte dans le fond ce projet de loi
que le gouvernement veut se garder
toutes les cartes ouvertes en quelque
sorte le Québec va pouvoir réglementer
va pouvoir encadrer va pouvoir
éventuellement interdire le recours aux
agents mais c'est pas monsieur Lapointe
la fin des agences privées loin de là
comment vous accueillez le projet de loi
vous pour nous le projet de loi dans sa
forme actuelle ce qu'il signifie c'est à
terme 1900 infirmières de moins dans le
réseau de la santé publique et des
milliers de travailleurs pourquoi moins
de travailleurs dans le réseau public
parce que nos entreprises place leur
personnel dans le réseau de la santé
publique et nos employés ont été très
clairs dans un sondage récent qu'on a
fait parvenir à plus de 2000 répondants
qu'il ne souhaite pas intégrer le réseau
de la santé l'ont quitté pour des
raisons aussi diverses que légitime et
maintenant de dire qu'on va faire un
changement de culture dans le réseau qui
va s'inscrire dans le respect des
professionnels mais qui ce changement de
culture là le geste fondateur ce soit de
leur dire écoutez on vous respecte même
pas assez pour respecter votre choix de
le choix de votre employeur et votre
choix l'autodétermination pour nous
c'est c'est contradictoires et selon nos
chiffres 80% des gens ne souhaitent pas
réintégrer le réseau de la santé et vous
vous voulez certainement pas perdre vos
travailleurs ou en tout cas les agences
privées ne veulent pas perdre leur
travailleur dans ce secteur-là mais en
même temps Madame Bouchard de l'autre
côté le gouvernement dit on va les
ramener dans le public mais est-ce que
les conditions sont rassemblées pour
aller chercher quoi jusqu'à 125 000
travailleurs exactement dans le fond ce
qu'il faut prendre en considération
c'est que évidemment que dans le
contexte actuel les professionnels en
soins qui sont actuellement dans les
agences ne veulent pas revenir au public
puisque les conditions de travail sont
tellement difficiles alors ce qu'il faut
faire c'est travailler les deux dossiers
en même temps donc oui on pousse pour
éventuellement abolir complètement les
agences de placement et en même temps
s'assurer que les conditions de travail
au public soit dorénavant nettement
supérieur aux agences puisque les
professionnels en soins qui ont décidé
de s'en aller vers les agences c'est
vraiment pour des questions de
conditions de travail alors
non puisque ça ça fait partie de notre
négociation nationale et c'est vraiment
ce que l'on veut rendre encore plus
attrayant le réseau public avec des
meilleures conditions de travail mais
les infirmières infirmières auxiliaires
inhalothérapeute n'auraient pas quitté
le public si les agences n'auraient pas
offert des conditions de travail
beaucoup plus intéressantes mais aussi
les salaires beaucoup plus intéressants
quand on dit Monsieur Lapointe que ça
coûte 3 milliards depuis six ans à
l'état pour faire appel aux agences
privées qui a des agences qui réclament
jusqu'à 100 dollars de l'heure et
peut-être même un peu plus d'abord
est-ce que c'est vrai et est-ce que
c'est de l'argent public bien placé ça
écoutez quand on parle de 3 milliards
sur les 6 dernières années c'est
important de remettre ce chiffre là en
contexte ça représente 500 millions par
donc moins d'un pour cent de l'enveloppe
totale du budget de la santé donc
essentiellement les agences de placement
coûtent moins d'un pour cent du budget
total du réseau de la santé et ça on
veut réellement considérer le coût d'une
agence de placement il faut comparer le
coût d'une agence avec le coût de
remplacement c'est à dire qu'ils sont
devenait une baguette magique et un
intervenant et qui faisait disparaître
tous les employés du réseau des agences
privées de même matin ces gens-là
soignent des patients et des patients
s'en vont nulle part donc ce 3 milliards
on aurait pu l'investir dans le réseau
public de façon améliorer le réseau
public madame Bouchard tout à fait 500
millions on peut vraiment faire beaucoup
de choses pour améliorer les conditions
de travail des professionnels en soins
ce n'est pas banal juste pour vous
donner un exemple en habitivité
médicament qui ont un statut particulier
de mémoire ces deux ou trois millions
qu'on leur octroyés pour essayer de
faire de la rétention au sein des
fidèles au public alors imaginez avec
500 millions tout ce qu'on pourrait
faire dans l'ensemble du Québec pour les
professionnels en soins monsieur la
pointe donc on dit que le gouvernement
va aller chercher 125 000 travailleurs
de la santé d'ici 5 ans pour les ramener
les attirer dans le réseau public le
gouvernement prévoit imposer aussi par
règlement les tarifs maximum que le
gouvernement va payer pour embaucher du
personnel d'agence ou indépendant vous
allez vous préparer comment à faire face
à ces changements-là permettez-moi
rapidement avant de répondre à cette
question là juste précisé ma pensée
quand on parlait en terme de coût 500
millions c'est le coût total des agences
et si on remplace les agences pour les
employés du public vous comprenez que
c'est pas 500 millions on en veut le
résiduel disponible dans bien des cas on
remplace des gens qui se rendent
supplémentaires ont temps
supplémentaires obligatoires donc le
coût financier humain de remplacer les
agences fait qu'il ne restent pas 500
millions par année je tiens à le
préciser je m'excuse mais sur votre
prochaine question maintenant comment
est-ce qu'on peut se préparer en tant
qu'industrie essentiellement ce que nous
on sait et ce qu'on cherche à faire
comprendre au gouvernement c'est que les
agences de placement le rôle
complémentaire dans le réseau de la
santé on représente bon âme allant
depuis des décennies 3 à 4% des heures
travaillées dans le réseau donc de
prétendre que les enjeux de rétention de
main-d’œuvre les enjeux d'attraction de
main d'oeuvre du réseau de la santé sont
sont mises en échec par des agences de
placement qui sont là pour trop 4 % des
heures par année je pense que c'est de
servir de nous comme d'un bouc émissaire
OK et Madame Bouchard je termine avec
vous quand le ministre du B dit que la
réussite du changement est vraiment liée
au négociations collectives qui sont en
cours là entre les travailleurs de la
santé puis le Conseil du Trésor vous
demandez quoi exactement au gouvernement
pour faire fonctionner le virage
premièrement des meilleures conditions
de travail c'est inévitable deuxièmement
avoir accès nous aussi en tant que
professionnel en soins dans le réseau
public à une conciliation travail
famille et troisièmement évidemment tout
ce qui est rémunération alors les
négociations nationales sont débutées
depuis la fin janvier par contre c'est
très lent puisque nous sommes à la table
une journée par période de deux semaines
nous ce qu'on veut c'est un rythme
soutenu pour aller beaucoup plus
rapidement depuis le 7 novembre 2022 que
nous sommes prêts et les 60 demandes qui
font partie de nos demandes concernant
la négociation nationale proviennent
réellement des 80 000 professionnels en
soins que l'on représente alors elles
sont légitimes pour la suite des choses
madame Bouchard monsieur la pointe merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]